[Music]
a pickaxe shatters the rocky wall of a
mine shaft hundreds of feet below the
earth it's 1871 in a place that will
later be known as columbia county
pennsylvania men performing
back-breaking labor their hands and
faces blackened with dirt all working in
pursuit of that immensely valuable rock
coal it's the fuel for the booming
industrial revolution and much like how
dragons were said to guard gold this
more modern treasure pointed to an even
more terrifying monster a monster that
the scp foundation would someday come to
know as scp-1179
but these unfortunate and underpaid
miners had no idea what they were about
to discover one of the men working there
that day rob o'dwyer was hammering away
at the wall in front of him when he
heard something strange was that an echo
behind the rocks this could mean only
one thing the rocks in front of them
were hollow there had to be some kind of
space hiding behind them o'dwyer struck
again and again at the rocks in front of
him until the barrier finally tumbled
away he and the other miners suddenly
felt a gust of cool ancient air from the
vast and darkened cavern in front of
them sweep through the mine they felt
like they were standing on the edge of
something truly otherworldly as they
lifted their safety lamps high and crept
carefully into the dark it dawned on
them that they were likely the first
human beings to ever set foot here but
that didn't mean something non-human
hadn't gotten there first o'dwyer's lamp
soon found something in the dark a huge
figure curled into a crouching position
hiding its face it was made from stone
like an enormous yet incredibly detailed
statue of something almost human but not
quite the petrified thing had two great
horns on either side of its head
twisting into spirals like that of a
huge ram word of the giant frozen
monster hidden in the bottom of the mine
soon made its way back to the foreman
and then back to the mine's owner won
sean o'malley if it were anyone else
perhaps this news would have been taken
to the press immediately and the
foundation would have taken control of
the situation just as quickly but mr
o'malley was no ordinary mining magnet
he was a member of the molly maguires an
irish-american secret society whose
members were predominantly coal miners
in pennsylvania shawn and the other
molly maguires dubbed this anomaly the
sleeping stone giant and conspired to
keep it a secret between them as secret
societies have a habit of doing though
the molly maguires were disbanded less
than a decade later they were all sworn
to secrecy on the giant's resting place
until of course a descendant of sean
o'malley his grandson ian o'malley was
chosen as a prospective agent of the scp
foundation the foundation doesn't just
let anyone join their ranks they perform
an extensive background check on all
prospective agents both to find out that
they're capable of rising to the
challenges of the job and also to detect
any affiliation to enemy groups of
interest it was during this background
check that o'malley's subterranean
family secret was discovered and the
land above the old mine shaft was bought
up by a front company owned by the
foundation the sleeping stone giant was
finally incapable hands and in keeping
with standard procedure a research site
was built above the giant to gather data
and keep an eye on things at the time
the anomaly was considered extremely low
risk its containment file read
scp-1179 is apparently dormant encased
in the bedrock under research site apart
from simple monitoring and standard
research safety protocols no additional
containment is deemed necessary at this
time but of course those simple
containment procedures would soon need
updating in 1962 the town of centralia
pennsylvania had a trash problem there
were eight illegal trash dumping sites
across the town and to combat this issue
the town council opened up a huge
landfill in an abandoned mine shaft
you'd think this would be enough for the
moderately sized town but humans have a
tendency to produce a lot of trash and
they soon filled up the new landfill too
in order to address the issue the town
decided to do a controlled burn of some
of the garbage it should have been
simple enough but those who lit this
garbage fire didn't follow proper safety
procedures and ended up accidentally
igniting a seam of anthracite coal this
was like lighting the fuse to the
world's largest stick of dynamite and
fire soon coursed through the long
abandoned mine tunnels when the fireball
finally reached the sleeping stone giant
in this dark pit the beast woke up in
that instant an otherwise uneventful day
quickly became a brutal bloodbath
researchers walking through the base
felt a monstrous rumbling beneath them
heat sensors were burning up and seismic
readings were off the scale something
was climbing up towards them suddenly an
impossibly large sword speared its way
out of the floor killing everyone around
it with an immense blast of heat the
newly awakened monster went on an
underground rampage almost completely
destroying the research base and killing
nearly everyone inside before retreating
into the honeycomb of coal mines and
caverns in the area igniting even more
anthracite coal fires the foundation
needed to step in before things really
got out of control at present the
foundation couldn't properly administer
standard area construction protocols for
ketter class scps so they instead
designated the mines caverns and
surrounding countryside as area 179 and
dispatched mobile task forces to try and
contain the beast rampaging in the
centralia mines but much like the fire
that started this whole mess the beast
proved much harder to control than
initially imagined all five of the
expeditionary teams sent to apprehend
the monster failed and many team members
were slaughtered in the process from the
terrifying accounts of the survivors we
have a vague idea of the nature of the
beast below no pictures of the creature
exist and exact descriptions on the
beast can vary whether this is because
the beast frequently shapeshifts or
because it has some kind of
cognito-hazardous effects on those who
view it is unclear the most frequently
reported characteristics of the creature
are its immense height and the extreme
heat that its body exudes many report
that the creature's body seemed to be
formed of a mix of hardened lava pure
fire and burning smoke the beast
measures over 30 meters from head to toe
with shoulders over 8 meters wide it's
commonly said to have two huge ram-like
horns and a weathered bearded face the
beast has been compared by some to the
norse mythological figure sirter the
giant guarding the frontier of the norse
fire realm of mooseball however the
actual age of the creatures seems to
predate these legends by a considerable
margin dating of the stratum encasing
scp-1179
indicates it dates to the mississippian
sub-period of the carboniferous period
approximately
359.2 to
318.1 million years ago this age is
consistent with the geological age of
this region so it may have literally
come with the territory less common
descriptions of the bees claim that it
has huge wings eyes made of hellfire and
fangs as long as a man's arm some say
that the beast has neither horns nor
fangs and its face is encircled by
flames which reach down into a long
beard of fire and like a certain
creature known as the balrog that lord
of the rings fans will be very familiar
with this beast comes with weapons in
one hand the beast wields a giant
burning sword around 5 meters in length
in the other it wields a huge
multi-tailed whip made out of fire it's
incredibly proficient with these weapons
too and has a serious strategic
advantage in its underground environment
foundation researchers have determined
that some of the wounds the beast gained
from its first confrontation haven't
fully healed implying the beast could in
theory be destroyed with enough
firepower however given that the beast
has killed almost everyone who faced it
and its mere presence can start almost
uncontrollable fires direct engagement
would only be used as a last resort even
the creature's breath can be extremely
dangerous chemical analysis of air
samples taken from
scp-1179's breath have shown
exceptionally high concentrations of
carbon monoxide and sulfur dioxide the
very presence of this creature creates a
real and active danger to everyone
around it and the beast presence was
beginning to have seriously negative
effects on the people up above by the
1970s the foundation had given up on
sending mobile task forces into the
caverns and instead began to focus on
depopulating the town of centralia to
prevent further fatalities from the
presence of
scp-1179 subterranean activities of the
creature were causing collapses in some
areas and noxious fumes were beginning
to rise up from cracks in the ground as
the constant raging fires burned beneath
the earth they were causing everything
above to slowly melt or bake a
foundation geologist determined that the
fires created by the beast would likely
remain active for 250 years and any
attempts to put out the fires or contain
the bees would ultimately be futile this
led to the formation of project tartarus
a concerted effort to cover up scp-1179
and fully evacuate the citizens of
centralia they pushed the narrative that
the mine fires while deadly were merely
the result of the failed garbage burning
plan and little by little the people of
centralia began to move away by 1984 the
united states government finally caved
to secret lobbying from the foundation
and allocated funds in excess of 42
million dollars to relocate the
remaining civilian residents from the
area any legal complaints from centralia
residents were quietly crushed by the
foundation and efforts to remove pretty
much all residents from the area were
successful this allowed the foundation
to finally cast a wider net and
administer kettier-class containment
protocols around the two kilometer
underground zone where
scp-1179 resides the foundation has
continued studies on the beast from
below in the decades since with some
scientists even suggesting it could be
used to produce geothermal energy but
whether or not that would actually be
feasible remains unknown for now
scp-1179 seems content to stay within
its zone and hopefully it stays that way
but as we're forced to dig deeper and
deeper for the remaining precious metals
here on earth there's no telling what
new dangers we might find lurking far
below the ground now go watch scp-2000
deus ex machina and
scp-2935 oh death for more freaky places
under the scp foundation's watch